[Music]
so welcome everyone this lecture will be
playing about playing like the pros or
at the very least like one of them
you'll be all relieved to know I'm not
gonna show a game of mine I know I'm I'm
actually gonna focus on a game of Paul
Karras and he's actually one of my
favorite players he was for those of you
who don't know he would never made world
champion but he's considered one of the
strongest players never to have made it
he has to my knowledge A+ record against
almost all the world champions he's
played apart from maybe one like you
know in later years he may be played
Karpov or something when he was much
weaker but an older but for about five
decades he was one of the top chess
players in the world there are not many
players who can who can say that so a
very impressive player one of my
favorite players um so I'm gonna go over
a game of his against Mac server who you
guys might know was actually a world
champion I would say he was not a player
of kerasys caliber he you know won the
World Championship he you know was
obviously an extremely strong player but
if you look at his overall results
probably not quite as strong actually so
that gives you an idea of how strong
Karras is so one of the reasons I like
him as a player is because if you asked
to define someone's style like say Tom
right what would you say is his style
yeah
attacking tactical aggressive it doesn't
mean he couldn't do things like playing
games but you know in fact he was a
quite a competent game player I think
but it wasn't really what he was known
for he wasn't known for positional just
as much he was known as an attacker now
say take Karpov
what would you say his specialty was in
games more positional chess and again
believe me Karpov could attack extremely
well he could do most things well to be
a world champion you can't just do one
thing but least to my knowledge but
that's kind of what he was known for I
would say with Karras he was more
balanced Spassky maybe you could put in
this category as well but basically I
would say Karras was an aggressive type
player he liked to play with the
initiative but he could play more
solidly too he could play positionally
he could play tactically I would say
that he was really a universal player
and if you look at his games you see
games of all different types and it's
one of the reasons why I really like him
as a player and I think this game
illustrate Sitwell because for a lot of
the game he has to defend but then the
second the tables turn he goes in the
offensive and right away kind of takes
the game from over so we start out with
double King pawn
yes Karras is black I suppose I'll flip
the board just for fun Bishop e5 how
many of you guys know what this is
called
it's the Steines deferred for some
reason the the Russian guys I know call
it the Stein it's preferred or the
preferred Stein it's no American I know
calls it that but I have you know most
people call it the Stein is deferred so
that's what I caught status preferred is
a little bit you know too too
presumptuous like you're really sure
it's better but okay but the idea of
course is that with the moves a six
Bishop a4 thrown in what option does it
give black which is often a very
important option yeah
well 9 of 6 playing a 6 does not give
you the option of a negative 6 but I
would say that it does give you the
option of b5 which is an important
option to have there are times when if
white plays d4 for instance this is
actually a very cool trick for you guys
who haven't known it with the with the
pomp back on a7 and the bishop here d4
is actually the main move and usually
you have to take play Bishop d7 your
position ends up being a little bit
passive not horrible but passive whereas
here you can play b5 Knight takes d4 and
white actually should play a move like
c3 probably but there's a very cool
trick if white takes here
it's called Noah's Ark trap so anyone
have an idea what it could be but double
attack guys hello is anyone scared all
right no one scared there should be six
defending don't draw me look a little
ahead Bishop d7 Queen has to go back
whoopsie the rooks defended now so you
have time to play c4 kind of a cool
trick huh
as yet no one has fallen for this I've
actually played the I've added the
Queens gambit declined in my repertoire
recently so no one has yet done this I'm
hoping the main reason I play d6 is to
hope someone falls for this so I can win
a piece but you know we'll see hasn't
happened yet I'm not holding my breath
in any case white played c3 which is the
main move Bishop d7 d4 so black played
97 I would say this move is more rare
now most players prefer to play a fee
and shadow setup even Knight f6 the
putting the net on e7 is considered
slightly dubious not that it means it's
some horrible move but it's not really
topical these days it can be a little
awkward in some positions so here white
played Bishop b3
so what would you guys play now h6 is
what was played which is an important
move Wow
let's say are you you were to play g6
which is a more natural developing move
right you want to play Bishop g7 and
castle there's a very big problem here I
would say so don't do this to yourself
in the opening it's very depressing
you can play Knight a5 it's a little bit
weird though because first of all you're
hanging a pawn if Knight g5 the idea by
the way is to take the bishop first and
then play d5 and you kind of get out of
it maybe not so clear just because
you've taken the bishop you've taken
White's best piece but okay it's a
little bit weird to play Knight a5
it's a very computer ish type move but
it might be playable in anything we
Karras played Asus h6 which is the main
move white plays ninety to ninety six
ninety four all fairly typical mm-hmm
yeah Knight f6 is fine blatant players
off and play with g6 Bishop g7 is a more
modern trend but you have lots of
options there yeah so castles castles so
it's kind of a normal position but you
can guess what Black's problem tends to
be here and it or Kenya now you guys can
get what is Black's problem here mostly
it's a more general state of blacks
position more than a specific move I
know what you meant and you're
absolutely correct
Black's cramped right like all these
pieces are kind of getting in each
other's way it's just annoying
so that tends to be Black's problem in
all these setups I'm like in Lopezes
where black tries to play b5 black plays
more aggressively here black just tends
to be cramped and it's why one of the
reasons why people are feared shadowing
the bishop now because it tends to be a
slightly less cramped version than this
but I can tell you when you play the
Stannis deferred incorrectly something
which I have definitely done this is
often what happens you end up in a
cramped position and it's not always a
lot of fun but one of the things I
wanted to highlight about Karras as a
player is that he could you could put
him under the defensive you could put
him on the on the offensive you can give
him any type of position and he'll
handle it properly for the most part so
even though he ended up in this position
which to my mind is a little passive
he's like all right we'll just slowly
improve my pieces so 93 was played he
played Bishop f6
95 so the question is how do you how do
you play now ah
I fear though you're you're kind of
neglecting your night I think we talked
about neglecting the night on H 5 in the
previous lecture now we got to talk
about neglecting this one it's okay to
put a net on a 5 but you have to
remember eventually it's got to come
back it does not want to chill out there
for the whole game
so after C 6 I would also suspect you
have some weaknesses here so I would in
this position if I were white I would
look for a way to punish you quite
severely I know it sounds like a
bullying thing to do but I don't know
even taking this bishop I assume you
take with Queen takes here I'm not sure
I trust your position here you have to
take with Knight right otherwise you
hang this guy
maybe I would say f5 comes I would say
your position is extremely unpleasant
would you agree not saying you're dead
lost but I would say I would certainly
choose to be white here there is no way
I would take blacks position
this guy's weak this guy's out of play
this King is potentially weak after
something like f5 I would not want to
have to play black here so you have to
be careful I mean there's this is the
problem when you have a passive position
there's a tendency to want to fix it
right away sometimes you can't fix it
right away
sometimes you have to remain passive for
a little while you should always be on
the lookout for active ideas I liked
that you were doing that I think that's
a good habit but you can't rush it
sometimes you have to play a little
slower rook e8 looks like a perfectly
fine move he opted to actually take this
pawn first sometimes people this is a
tendency which I would say back before
Karras is time taking this pawn was
considered a fish move like ah some
amateur giving up their Center but now
that's not this kind of capture is made
all the time and the reason why is
because often times it's hard to advance
this Center and sometimes these pawns
become weaknesses rather than strengths
and it helps black 4 get away to
counter-attack so I'm not saying taking
this pawn is always a good thing there
are times when if you give white this
center you're gonna regret it but
sometimes to get counter play you have
to give white this Center you have to
make this capture but I would say that
again long before this game this would
be a very unusual capture this would be
like ah some idiot now it's pretty
common but yeah black could have
possibly played rook e8 some moves like
this you have to be careful sometimes
with this Bishop you don't want f7 to
become tender at the wrong moment but 9
h4 is possible the only thing is you
might find yourself a little slow the
problem when you get rid of this Knight
is that now and all of a sudden it's
like whoa sometimes this can really make
you make your position
very fast right you have to make sure
you don't accelerate your opponents
attack the matter of three might be an
okay piece but it also keeps white at
bay so he opted to take night takes and
again it was maybe possible for white to
take with the pawn but I don't know
rookie eights it's still caught looks
quite I don't know if it would be to my
taste one one movie did have though is
because white has not played h3 yet this
is a very common idea and this was
almost certainly his idea actually so
that's the thing when you take on d4
often the plan is you have this Bishop
g4 move so this is why white often plays
aged thirty early by the way so that was
his idea but now that White's taken this
way you don't have to give white the two
pawns in the center
he played rookie eights and white took
on f6 and I'd say this is a very common
type of move which I actually don't like
your opponent this Bishop on f6 is a
problem piece it's hanging all the time
it has no good moves taking a piece like
this you might get the two bishops but
it frees your opponent's position it
lets the Queen out right now the rooks
can't connect right when your opponent
has less space do not be in a hurry to
trade pieces even if you're taking what
you consider a good piece for your
opponent even if you know you're you're
winning the two bishops or you're doing
something like that if you trade too
much your opponent's position becomes
easier to play right so you want to make
sure that like again I would almost
certainly just drop my bishop back or
play rook e1 or something like this keep
the pressure up Queen age five oh my
goodness so you're trying to do
something tricky with this Knight
I don't know if this actually works
though what happens if I just take this
you do realize you're giving up lots of
pieces right I don't know if you can
take them all back quickly enough so I
might just be able to play Bishop e6 but
let's say I just don't trust you
95 actually would be just end it right
away but even if I let you take on f7 I
would say your position is quite bad
unless you have some trick but I don't
know 95 always I just don't believe it
you're giving away all your pieces it's
not your your attacks gonna go away if
you don't have pieces do remember anyway
I like your spirit though I gotta say
aggressive aggressive play but sometimes
it doesn't work right you have to rein
it in again I would probably just play
Bishop c2 or rook e1 just keep the
pressure on black ass black how are you
gonna finish your development the
problem Knight takes f6 is you're saying
you're gonna finish your development by
taking with the Queen
so you actually make your opponent's
life easier so I'm circus said thank you
very much half three Knight f4 so trying
to activate that guy maybe Knight takes
c6 Bishop takes so again probably I'd
still take white the two bishops
slightly more space but notice how once
you trade off a couple pairs of pieces a
little bit right I don't think black can
really generate a threat here but I
think that blacks position has become
easier to play right and why is it
become easier because the pieces have
come off right so Bishop e3 was played
broke piates all fairly normal right
Queen d2 knight retreats
your activity was gone right but it's
not such a big deal the knight can
retreat and go back Bishop to d4 okay
so note how he's not doing anything
crazy aggressive right he's not trying
to go forward he's not trying to do
anything he's just keeping his position
solid he's waiting so here white plays
rook there so does the Queen want to be
on e7 anymore okay
he's playing very slowly right but look
at blacks position are there any
weaknesses so when there are no
weaknesses usually it's hard for your
opponent to crack you so the key is not
to create weaknesses a lot of people
they don't have weaknesses but they
panic a little they see the do bishops
and they're like are I got to do
something but a lot of the times kind of
backfires on you so here I don't know I
was thinking about this move I didn't
test this with computers so I might just
be blundering but this was a move I
would really consider for power white so
I'm basically trying to be aggressive
and what happens if takes on e4 I could
have blundered it it's possible but yeah
well if I take this way I don't think
you want to play off five
I'm gonna take that
ah I don't know this might have been a
little bit tough to deal with I that's
the one thing with Queen d7 I didn't
like but white decided to play a little
differently I decided to make sure d5 is
not a move a little bit of an awkward
move so the question is what is black do
here so a move like b5 you have to be
careful with right now that pawn on c4
is doing what it's blocking the bishop
right when you play b5 you're opening
the position up now who are you opening
the position up for the bishop right so
if you play b5 for example your plans to
do what you have to be careful sometimes
when you do stuff like this all you end
up doing is ripping up your own position
not your opponent's so for example let's
say I were to play I don't know Queens
III check to your pawn
I always announce check to all pieces
it's why my opponents never bloom
hmm but now you have to watch out for a
for now I don't have to take that so yes
very nice trick if I take you take this
rook I'm not even sure that's good for
you by the way actually I'm just gonna
fall for it just because I'm bored
no but just illustrate a point sometimes
you allow this this night might be
trapped you might end up actually
regretting this big time I don't know
this is a little bit weird but I didn't
have to take on before either
I could play Queen back to D 2 for
example ah G 3 would be probably better
yeah I don't know I don't much like your
position right that's the thing
sometimes you push you try to get
counter play but you end up helping your
opponent so you have to be careful
you're not just kind of doing a break
because you want to do a break sometimes
a break is not the best thing your
opponent's the two bishops and if you
want you're trying to open the position
for them usually a bad idea
so black does something actually which i
think is an excellent positional
decision not an obvious one but a really
good one I think that Karis tended to be
very astute he'd know that if the
position was changing a little what he
had to do because he plays a move which
is probably not all that obvious but I
think it's the best move
he does indeed so at first you're
probably thinking we'll wait a second
why is he trading off this guy but he's
thinking ahead first of all who has less
space so who wants to trade pieces black
so you're following at least one rule
but you're trading off a pretty
weird-looking piece right but his
thinking is that if you give back time
to play Bishop c2 sorry give white time
to play Bishop c2 to play b3 to advance
your F pawn you're gonna end up
suffering and those bishops will be very
strong however if you trade off a bishop
you're gonna have more defensive ideas
you're gonna have more defensive plans
because why it's only gonna have one
bishop and you're gonna see how this
manifests itself so white captures you
capture Queen c3 but now you can safely
play which move 95 you're gonna run into
f4 again I would not want to torture
King said but you play f6 with the
bishops on the board this would be a
very weakening move you'd have to
contend with c5 check you'd have to
contend with all sorts of things
maybe Bishop drops back to c2 f45 and
the knight hangs now there's nothing
that takes advantage of your less course
so when you play f6 your position is
actually quite solid and how is white
gonna crack you here
on f6 you can try but I don't think I
think the best you can hope for here is
really perpetual because your rooks are
not attacking right so let's say I play
I don't know Nate f8 maybe yeah
take the pawn maybe Queen d7 even this
move is interesting trying to slide the
rook over the problem is that if you're
unless you get an attack you're actually
going to get attacked here the piece in
the middle game the piece tends to be
quite a bit better than the pawns so
even three pawns is probably not enough
not to mention you have all these pawns
just hanging right so you're probably
not gonna stay up these pawns so I don't
know my guess would be the Tiki nf6 the
best you can hope for there is actually
a draw I don't think you're really
trying to win with that move it's all
possible but as we discussed in the
previous game what's the problem with
advancing your whole King side your
kingka becomes weak first whites blacks
King only becomes a week after so I'm
not saying it's an impossible idea but
it's a risky idea
it forces white to take a risk and if if
you're playing a passive position that's
exactly what you want if your passive
and your opponent can just put pressure
on you with not weakening anything your
life's just gonna be miserable I had a
game actually in my last tournament that
was like this they had an initiative
they had a better pawn structure they
just put pressure on me I held but I did
not have a fun time play in that game
it's just not a lot of fun whereas if
they week after weaken themselves if
they have to take risks then you get to
a counter-attack them so I'm not saying
g4f for that these ideas are insane I
might say that but I would say that
there exists extremely risky and you're
gonna get a chance to counter-attack
because what always happens with these
ideas is that your kingdoms weak first
and black King only becomes a week later
if you get in g5 if you have the time
and often you don't have the time but
okay black white white did indeed play
up for black played King h7 keeping on
the knight right b3 queen drop back I
kind of like to see six but his move is
probably okay to and note how it's
really hard for black to do anything if
you play e5 I just take a bunch of times
if f5 95 this is why trading pieces is
such a powerful weapon when you have
less space
sounds weird to call it a weapon I
realized but basically once you have
less space if you trade the pieces you
can often just defend like this and it's
very difficult and meanwhile you have a
plan if white does nothing you can play
rook e7 Roky a queen c6 you're the one
who has a target what is white targeting
this pawn good luck right white is no
target and you have a target and again
this is why the more pieces you trade
the better it is when you have less
space most of the time obviously I'm
never gonna say all the time because
there are exceptions to everything but
so white played this so the question is
what is black do now so he could play
rook e7 rook e8 but my guess would be
that's he thought that was a little slow
it's probably not gonna do a lot so he
decided that now was the time now that
white moved the Queen over to f3 to play
for counter play of a different type now
he plays your move but it's completely
different there's no bishop you're
activating now right if pawn takes pawn
takes you have some at least some ideas
however he also had a trick because
white played here which to my mind looks
like actually a very logical move
because you don't really want to take on
c4 if y can take back with a piece right
so what do you want to play as take this
one okay queen two
so this is what I'd say if you have no
follow-up this move is terrible because
you've just weakened your pawn structure
right this is why you have to be careful
with captures were threatening all the
time like you have to see ahead because
you've worsened your pawn structure
right you have not improved it this is
why I would say that when you play moves
like b5 you should do so with caution
you want to make sure that you're not
just weakening yourself you want to make
sure you're creating weaknesses if why
did it take back with the pond you'd be
creating weaknesses right then White has
a worse pawn structure but if Y can take
back with the Queen all of a sudden your
pawn structure is not so good right hold
on a moment
so if Queen g4 here so you're trying to
play Knight to except for I presume the
only thing I would say is that now I
might actually worry about this move and
the reason is because now I don't like
your Queen now I think the Queen might
be slightly in this place although wait
9595 oh I'm you're attacking stuff
already yep
no you're correct that's not good so for
some reason I thought I could do it with
tempo but I could not yeah I don't know
it's an interesting move hmm b5 I think
you might live to regret that one that's
a lot of pieces aimed at you there
yeah queen g4 is a very tricky move I'm
not exactly sure what I would recommend
I mean maybe I can play g3 maybe this is
not as bad as I thought originally I
didn't want to play this move at all but
maybe it's not so bad because now b5 is
attacked I can always play Queen f3 if I
need to but I like your move it's it's
the right type of move I think it's
quite reasonable so you want a d5 here
it's possible so if I take you're gonna
just take everything so wait if takes
you're gonna play roof take c1 first
right and f4 is always gonna hang
because again in the end game you could
regret these pawns right these are not
good bonds to have an endgame but if f4
hangs here that might be more
interesting so yeah here I maybe got a
little bit sloppy maybe I have net h3
I don't know what's going on now uh
check here so I could maybe Glade King H
a rook g8 or I could even I mean I don't
think I mean really any danger here F
pawn who's the master of this yeah but
you're a little bit more passive so I
would say like I can keep checking
I guess it's two pawns but I don't know
here I would actually be very amazed if
blacks not drawing here just because of
how active how strong the King is
ripped a save six key after three BAM
just to show you ohoho active King
telling you people underestimate the
active King in that rook endgame so bad
it's unbelievable
that's what I'm telling you I just I've
seen enough of these I'm almost positive
blacks okay here not saying I'd be
willing to bet tons of money but I bet
you I if we turn on the computer here
what is it gonna say plus equal going
down equal oh yes
alright anyway enough celebrating anyway
the point is that you can see the active
King means a lot right very powerful so
and this line is completely relevant to
the game obviously I'm just kidding
black actually has a very very strong
move here and again it's the only reason
he did this is cuz he saw this move the
only reason he played b5 the only reason
he took on c4 is cuz he had a follow-up
whoops
so it's funny because at first your Lego
white just fell for a tactic but part of
the reason white fell to this tactic is
because black played very solid and was
slowly out playing him right black was
defending it first for a long time
slowly got a solid position this is
where you got to be on the lookout this
is where the very strongest players are
always kind of on the watch because they
all want to win it's not like people
just want to draw it's just sometimes
you have to play solidly when your
position is worse right but they're
always on the lookout for tactics
they're always trying to find a way to
turn the tables and this is quite a way
to do it
so rook takes e4 d5 and here I think
White's already in some trouble boy
grabs the pawn takes here Bishop e3 but
materials still even you can but my
question is do you want to how do you
decide if you want to trade Queens what
piece do you look at to decide that
usually hmm nope the Kings why the Kings
I could not have said it better myself
everything you said is correct your
opponent has a weak King and you don't
you want to keep those Queens on the
board you want that King feeling the
heat if you trade Queens when your
opponent is a weak King in some ways you
can think of it as almost giving up a
pawn giving up an exchange you're giving
up part of your advantage
materials only one thing that can make a
position better there's pawn structure
there's piece activity there's King
safety if your opponent's king is unsafe
and you trade Queens you're giving up
part of your advantage which means if
you do it they should have to pay a
hefty fine meaning lots of material
meaning you get some other advantage you
do not want to do it for free so if you
were to aim to trade Queens here I would
say that's almost a blunder simply
because White's King is way worse than
yours so you're basically just giving up
material it's how I would look at it I
know it's it's extreme but I actually
put those things in the same category
almost sometimes I put King safety above
material just goes with me and I like to
mess with people but it's true sometimes
having a weak King is worth a lot more
so I would say trading Queens here as
black is a very bad decision and you can
be rest assured Karis did not do this
yes let's start attacking right look at
White's King look at blacks King who is
the better minor piece this Knight now
is quite a piece come at age four
however I would say that Karis did not
usually he's very good at finishing
opponents off I would say he was not
super precise this game but the good
news is that means you guys get to play
better and I know you guys love playing
better than the world champions and
people like that
so for now though he plays quite well I
think you can although you have to
realize that takes on ephors check right
but threatening mate is always a good
move to look at I'm never gonna be upset
because my a student was like oh I
looked at matin one here it's always
like yes look at matin one always try to
threaten me so if you guys found a one
win here would not be surprising he
found a different choice though f5 I
actually think is a really good move
because then you secure everything and
you're basically like okay good luck
defending against rook t39 F 3 and the
zillion threats I have sorry f5 here
it's like alright Knight h4 cotton rope
d3 good luck have fun buddy
and I think f5 is actually a very good
move but he found something more
forceful kind of like you guys he wanted
to it immediately try to do something
but he didn't take that edge forward so
what would what other forceful moves are
available well okay first of all first
of all before you go too far do I have
to take on d1 I've noticed by the way
you in particular sometimes forget to
ask this you play a move in your leg
does my opponent and you assume your
opponent has to take you or has to kind
of do that always ask yourself do they
have to it's a question all of us a lot
of us forget our do our opponents have
to take us I don't know are you
threatening anything here is the world
on fire there's something going on I
mean I don't know I can take here
maybe I can't I mean it looks dangerous
but you learnt I mean am i forced to
take this but let's say I do take this
first of all your trading rooks not
something I want to do when you're
trying to attack do you and second I
mean I don't know I play King F - even
Queen F one might be a move it this does
not look forcing right this does not
look like you're gonna be winning
anything I don't know maybe you have
some idea but rook d1 I don't think is a
forcing move because you're not really
making a threat that was dramatic what
else we got although usually when I do
these lectures none of the questions
come through so it's just me talking to
myself so it's like me every day but you
know try to repeat them he chose this
one so you guys probably looked at this
but you missed that after Queen takes
pawn what does move does black half and
I have to admit when I played this
through this game I missed it for - at
first yeah kind of obvious when you
think about it but it's like I missed it
too it's easy to miss the idea of
courses that have rook f3 you're kind of
overloaded so you can just give a check
and then this Bishop well it's not quite
check me oh look do you want yeah it's
even stronger yeah I was like ah Queen
e1 I was so happy all right
anyway so he decides to play Bishop back
so now of course
Queeny to here's I think winning I think
f5 is still monstrous he chose this one
so again he's kind of like you guys in
that he wants to be forceful if he can
he wants to do things by force so his
idea was after take screw it takes here
Queen t2 was possible but even here even
if at five here it's still pretty much
winning yeah so he played here so here
he decided to get a little clever he
could play rook c3 first and just play
rook c2 and probably it's winning no you
have to realize guys this is a kind of
mistake I see a lot where it's like
people win material and they kind of
stop but it's like well wait a moment I
was probably mating before now wait a
second how do I win this position right
probably this is a draw right I mean the
rook and Bishop is often a fortress
against the Queen and I'm I even up a
pawn here right so you're not even up
material so you have to be very careful
about moves like rook f3 make sure your
opponent cannot basically diffuse your
whole initiative right
Brooke age three does it make a threat
notice how I asked that question every
time it's amazing how often you play it
like not you I mean there's people in
general you play it a move that you
think it's threatening and you're like
wait a second what am i threatening I'm
not threatening anything so make sure
even if a move looks threatening you're
asking yourself am i threatening
something because it's so often the
answer is just a maybe not
and it's always depressing when that
happens you play some awesome looking
move you think you're threatening the
world and it's like yeah here though he
does make a threat he makes a very
powerful threat I should say oh no rook
d1 he might be able to just move the
bishop
I don't know Bishop III mm-hmm looks
risky I don't give you that he actually
plays a very sneaky move this makes a
threat right and this is quite good
enough to win kind of clever huh he
wanted to do it all with tempo so he
attacks the Queen he wants to play rook
c2 obviously taking is not advisable so
yeah h3 maybe would have been a clever
move maybe the best try I don't know and
it's probably why rook c3 first was
simpler but okay white played Queen d5
so now what
he actually could have made a choice he
could have played rook c5 which is what
he played or rook c2 one move is
actually quite a bit better than the
other why
but the question is where is the queen
going to move rook t3 is possible but
I'm not gonna take it I'm gonna move
back to c6 right that's kind of the
position we just came from we just had
this position you can play rugby six but
now maybe I go back to c2 it's an
improvement right the Queen's better on
c2 then it was kind of out here you have
to be careful I mean it's tempting to
just keep chasing the Queen but
sometimes you chase it to better squares
not worth squares so you have to be
careful but yeah here between rooks c2
and rook c5 one's actually more precise
than the other I think they both win but
what
exactly if rook c2 now you go here Queen
d2 is not a defensive choice so the
Queen must go out this way and now you
have a very strong move b7 is possible
to they're the same basically but here
believe it or not Y can just resign
immediately it's just over you lose the
entire world not only do you lose a
piece you lose everything because what
can we do here when is no moves and
you're just gonna play Queen takes
bishop and rook c2 and ask white to
resign politely
so now I'd imagine there's a choice but
this I don't know this one looks kind of
strong you just have too much to defend
right
you have to probably go here I go here
looks kind of bad here I'll take it
ah there should be one here
there's too much to defend right so what
he did of course is still winning pretty
pretty simple but if white plays Queen
off - believe it or not you have to
trade rooks now kind of and I guess you
can move back like to see three butts at
least the game would be prolonged a
little bit I would say this is a mistake
that's pretty small I mean most people
are gonna lose here anyway but hmm you
could like queen d1 but the only problem
is I'm not actually sure you want to
trade everything look at your knight
look at these guys this is a case where
you're up a piece you don't want to
trade trading actually makes your life
way more complicated whereas if you keep
everything on the board I would probably
just go back say you're probably gonna
win this right because the king is still
weak the only thing is you don't win
immediately white gets to defend a
little while longer so he could have
ended the game completely immediately by
playing Brooksie - first what he did is
good enough white played this move
though but here black could have
actually won quite easily
night after check and the idea is that
now if king f2 so he actually missed
this I'm guessing he had no time here
because there's no way a player of his
strength is missing that f3 in normal
circumstances but I'm glad you guys
thought he played Queen g3 Queen e2 and
now he wonders so this kind of thing is
pretty easy to win but I would say that
what are the key things you have to
remember you're up a piece for a pawn
but what it what is your idea to win
here what do you want to do yeah I would
say no why would I say no to trading
pieces who is attacking black for sure
right look at this King you have an
extra attacking piece I don't see an
extra piece I see an extra attacking
piece it's true this is often the case
so if you trade Queens what are you
doing according to my silly rules losing
lets you're basically giving up material
part of your advantage is white squeak
King if you trade Queens
you're giving up part of your advantage
now there are exceptions if you trade
Queens and you get a ending that you can
win with your eyes closed at 2 a.m. then
fine if it's that easy then okay but I'd
say that unless that's the case you want
to keep Queens on so you can do what
checkmate or at least attack force white
to say give up another pond of trade
Queens force white to give up a Queen
side pawn force white to do something
unpleasant in order to avoid checkmate
it is
yeah pretty easily he just could have
won really easily
that was a long thing so 96 97 so he's
just bringing his knight back around
right then then rh4 looked nice but he
wasn't really making any threats
hey for Queen check Queen check 95 I'm
playing this over cuz you have lots of
good moves but note how he's bringing
his knight around because these squares
are looking kind of tasty right like I
would say I have a problem with students
doing this that they'll be up material
like this and they'll want to trade
Queens here is black I'm like why would
you ever want to trade Queens you're
attacking so you know simplifying is a
tricky concept I would say that
simplifying is something you want to do
in certain situations if your opponent
has counter play in your up material
then yes trading Queens is often the way
to go trying to trade pieces simplify
the game but if you are up material and
attacking if you're up material and have
the initiative you want to keep your
initiative you want to keep the game
keep it so you can make threats so you
can play against your opponent's pieces
against their king so if you have the
initiative if you have an attack do not
simplify almost never should you
simplify those are the cases where you
should be trying to keep the game not
complicated but keep your initiative
going right that makes sense and the
reason I mentioned this a lot is because
I just almost all my students say under
2000 under 2100 do the exact same thing
they want to trade Queens in their
position like this and I just want to
say no keep attacking aren't you kids
don't you like to attack what's going on
anyway so queen d1 was played tonight c3
I'll try not to shake my fists the rest
of the lecture Queen c2 and here he
decided to go on the attack
King g6 what's this idea of king g6 by
the way mm-hmm it's a white plate here
which is not a very good move
see what I mean so now all of a sudden
White has to defend so he goes here so
how to finish off the game
so night g3 so now you always have met
up one if you need it you're defending
your pawn white plate here give a check
what's he doing h5
not quite let's say I guess go here I'm
trying to push up on see why you play
for me because what are you gonna do
about this
he tried this move and again can you win
if you trade Queens probably but why
bother right thank you yes this is the
key you don't want to block your pawn so
you play a 93 and I think white doesn't
resign but yeah do this see how helpless
why this late at night f 193 mate is the
idea right the idea is not to trade quit
anyway so notice how like you can learn
from all phases of the game right I mean
yes it should be pretty easy to win up
up a night
but notice how he did it he didn't he
wasn't in a rush she didn't just trade
queens he brought his knight into the
game he went after White's King and the
game kind of winds itself even if a
computer can prevent you from mating
them for a while most humans even very
strong ones cannot they're eventually
gonna blunder they're eventually gonna
miss something and you just put it makes
your win so much easier because you're
not really taking a risk because the
Queen's are on the board you're the one
attacking but anyway so I hope you
enjoyed the game again I think Karis is
a good player to learn from because he
shows you that you have to be good at
all the phases of the game not that
other world champions other strong
players weren't but in particular with
him I would say he was good at playing
each type of position whether very
locked very very open and if you look at
more of his games you'll see that and I
think that as a especially if you're a
young player but even if you're you know
just trying to improve at any level at
any age trying to learn to play
different types of positions ones you
don't like as much ones you aren't good
at is very important because do you
think he was happy at the beginning of
the game having to defend all like that
probably not right but he still did what
he had to do waited for his opportunity
and you saw how he capitalized when he
did get the advantage right
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]